thank you
[Music]
so there's a teacher in Italy who got
fired
because she was not doing her job for 20
years I thought the French were lazy
Italians are lazier
dang man yeah so she um 20 years it took
him 20 years to figure that out she's a
secondary school teacher she specializes
in history and philosophy ah those are
the you could get away with jobs and she
says that she has she has the documents
to prove her story that she did show up
to her job but she's at the beach right
now so she can't
I see she actually did say that to the
Republican newspaper yeah that's funny
she says I'll reconstruct the truth of
The Facts of this absolute unique and
surreal story but I don't answer
questions from journalists thrown around
that wouldn't do justice to the truth of
my story
so she was
um but when I get back from vacation
I'll tell you everything so complicated
yeah so they're arguing the people who
fired her that she had kept out of the
classroom for 20 out of her 24 years she
still got paid being employed there damn
and for the first 10 years she was
completely absent whoa and well that's
on them dude wait so the kids just show
up to an empty classroom and they just
go okay we'll just sit here for an hour
I think she somehow got lost in the mix
so she was just collecting checks and
they just weren't even she won dude
she's the winner first 10 years of her
employment she she didn't even show up
and her absences were attributed to
sickness personal or family reasons and
there was no follow-up she was just like
I don't know what though that's like
laziness on so many levels that's
several chains of like not checking
right I don't think I don't think that's
her fault anymore there's that timeline
10 years 10 years she was just wasn't
there isn't that kind of Genius you got
away with it for that long definitely
you gotta take down that whole pillar
then yeah I think maybe one way is if
you if you're like the VCR Roland TV
teacher you put that in and they just
have a timer where like it starts off
with text already if you can't if you've
come in here just sit down open your
books and then you just start playing
the video and it just repeats every hour
they may be like that but you know
what's funny if you were a student of a
teacher like this you wouldn't rather
out nah [__] no that's true that's my
favorite class ever because
kick there might be a couple people that
might get mad like a couple kids oh
there's always
squares
you gotta beat them up you got to beat
this guy wanted to learn Greek
philosophy and you're not even here to
teach me Shut the [__] up Carl a classic
Italian name Carl that's when we
overturn the trash can on their head
yeah yeah
remember those kids that are like oh oh
and the bell ring teacher you forgot to
give us homework I wanted a [__]
pulls up so bad it is a cliche but it
does happen I did only see that happen
in movies though
experience really really I remember a
kid that actually specifically saying
you forgot to give us home you didn't
have enough Asians in your class oh
probably not yeah because usually an
Asian kid they always did that you guys
actually remember someone saying that
yeah dude in college yeah it was in
college I heard a lot wait wait because
because it'll be like frantic the bell
ring she was probably still lecturing or
whatever and then like it's like
everyone's like oh [__] go before she
gives us homework yeah
she did give us I'll be like oh then
aren't we supposed to have a quiz today
and they're like shut up yeah
that has happened oh God damn your mom
hates you yeah
that beat your mom prepped so hard that
they didn't want to like miss out on
yeah and I'm like you
but what about the rest of us that don't
study but they also do that [__] too
where it's like they want to look
smarter yeah
dude and it's like well I prepare for
the quiz I want to thank you yeah yeah
and they're like correcting the teacher
in a way and they get off on that [__]
yeah they love it collecting homework
that was always a thing oh you forgot to
collect the homework from yeah yeah yeah
yeah do we turn into homework and you're
like [__] guy dude [__] car all
the time I remember having to do a book
report and then I didn't even read a
book and then I had made up the whole
book that's tight damn that's tight
I used to just write it for no reason
like the book reports of what I felt
that day and I just turned it in and get
a deep Journal yeah I get a d dude like
yeah I was picking graster in recess
yeah like what does that have to do with
this because I was like this is a way
better story like this book sucks my
life is better and then I would write
and then give it to someone my life is
better
when you guys see uh protest for like
teachers arguing for like higher wages
does your mind go to the good teachers
that deserve it or the bad teachers that
don't
I always think about the bed
I would say most of the schools I've
been to half of the teachers were lazy
about half yeah they would they weren't
even teaching or they just read out of
the book and they just let you chill
they pitched the most too about patient
I go to the why'd you sign up for that
job
yeah that's my go-to thing because I'm
like you know how much you're gonna get
paid before you signed yeah but what if
they love teaching then shut the [__] up
and go teach yeah I'm like what the [__]
like if you if they go hey LM XYZ
Elementary School this is how much
you're gonna get paid like it's weird to
me to go okay I'll take this for like
two years and then like a year later
wait a minute but they also get Summers
off too dude you know what I kind of
just go teach out a private school gonna
make more money but I do agree I think
teachers should get paid more overall
because it's a really difficult job so
as a as a system I think teachers should
get paid more and they're educating our
kids in the future but individually I'm
like why'd you yeah why'd you choose
something and then complain about it
yeah because if they do it raise the
rates on how much uh teachers get paid
it could attract more higher like better
teachers right well I don't know how
other states are but in California you
get your school loans excused if you go
oh you exactly so like you're if you
teach at a public yeah is that if you
teach public yeah really not if you go
to like teach at a private school right
no it's public school so there's like
loan forgiveness stuff so like when I so
when we were that's one of the things I
was considering too because I was like
man you get Summers off see it was like
my lazy mind thinking like I I want the
job not because I'm passionate about
like mentoring and teaching but because
I want the most pay and then the most
breaks but you know what's sad though
that they do get Summers off but they
don't get Summers paid because you only
get paid to teach so a lot of teachers
during the summer like [__] what do I do
like how do I make income yeah if you're
on tenure do you still get paid for like
the I don't think so I think if you have
if you're off you're not gonna get paid
so like they actually don't get paid the
12 months like one of the homies that's
a teacher says like it's like kind of
adjusted Forum oh really it's like yeah
it's like they'll be able to so it's not
like a total like yeah it's not a
complete yeah deficit but it also
depends on the state something like he
would get paid then yeah for sure that's
that's why a lot of teachers do to
summer school my friend's mom um she's a
junior high teacher she was making six
figures as a tenure teacher sick
but good I don't know but she was like a
bank teller and then decided to go back
to school with and then
um you know to go and become a teacher
for junior high and then she worked
um and and I think yeah she was he was
like yeah my mom makes like 110 or some
[__] and I'm like what as a teacher but
also you make more when you're going to
like lower income schools too because
there's more funding there you know you
know something weird which maybe some of
you guys have maybe noticed and I
definitely noticed so like growing up
most teachers tell you they love
teaching and that's why they do it and
some of them are really good now that
you've had friends that you grew up with
that went to school and decided to be
teachers
I've noticed all my friends that decided
to do that and I have a lot of them they
all did it because they didn't know what
else to do and now they love teaching
now that they grew they grew to love it
right right but it wasn't that they
always had this quest to like become a
teacher because they love the idea they
just literally all of them Shrugged and
they were like I just I don't [__]
hate being a teacher because you
use homework right like you finish
school you're like thank God no more
[__] Homer but now you gotta grade
all these papers yeah [__] that but I
think for them like when I asked them
what they love about it it's depending
on what school they're teaching at
because they moved around now they love
it because they love where they teach
but they hate it at certain others a lot
of people a lot of teachers too opt for
teaching abroad and teaching English and
they actually make it just a straight up
hack they make a ton of money dude I had
a lot of homies that did that in Asia I
think they're able to travel you're able
to and [__] Asian prostitutes yeah huge
plus tourism yeah I heard that like the
students abroad are way more easier
because they're like orderly they're
respectful they don't have to play
babysitter oh yeah classroom full of
Asian kids yeah that's a dream yeah yeah
so if you're gonna be a teacher teach
abroad yeah teach a bunch of Asians dude
imagine teaching at Arcadia High School
everyone wants to do homework everyone
wants to learn those kids are smart too
dude dude you have to admit though Bart
like if you were grading paper you'd
just be [__] going hey whatever it is
everyone's getting an a exactly except
for the [__] kid that pisses me off
I'm gonna [__] nitpick and find a way
to get my f but your friends that you
grew up with that became teachers I only
know one person that was her goal to be
a teacher like she was passionate about
it everything
um and I know another uh person that's
on their way to and they're very
passionate about it but yeah like most
people I know I don't think that was
their first choice I think it was
something that was a necessity because
they needed to find something that was a
guarantee or maybe they had kids early
and they're just like how do I balance
this out and it worked out for their
lifestyle yeah but it wasn't a passion
to follow I only knew one and I was
horny for her because I was a freshman
she was a senior right and then when she
graduated I was like oh toodaloo I never
see you again but then she was one of
those that finished college early so
when I was a senior she she came back
and I was like oh [__] she came back to
teach and now we have the student
teacher relationship that would be crazy
but nothing nothing
huh you didn't try to like shoot your
shot with her
I think when you're 17 into like 23 is
kind of hard I think I don't know I
think that's just self-limiting brain I
think if you believe you could do it you
could do it brother you got a fresh and
fit your [__] mind bro
have you ever watched our podcast
how do you live I need to subscribe how
do you uh make decisions because
apparently to them like women are dumped
yeah you can trick them in and do
anything oh I feel like the the whole
um system probably makes people like
super unmotivated too like let's say
you're a teacher you have all these like
things you want to do you have energy to
try new things and then you go in and
it's like so much bureaucracy so much
laziness whatever and then it's like
you're in this system you're just like
[__] man this is soul crushing I also
think some people that get into teaching
they think they have their expectation
of it is going to be like oh it's gonna
be fun it's gonna be cool and then they
realize how many skills you need to have
to be able to like Wrangle a classroom
room and do all that stuff and you're
just getting beaten down by these kids
all the time it takes a while to find
your strides yeah definitely right like
you're definitely not the teacher that
you were when you started yeah exactly
when you first started teaching kids and
you're not really experienced in doing
that you're just getting dunked on
constantly it feels like you're drowning
everyone of type of teachers I'm buying
them a [__] gift basket of some sort
yeah really tight is a pain in the [__]
and so like anyone that's teaching taika
I'm like you're amazing I blame the
parents grease them Wheels baby
[Music]
hmm